في هذه الأزمة غير المسبوقة ،
يتم إعادة اختراع الضيافة co vid 19
غير كل شيء فندق Four Seasons هو
أحد أفخم الفنادق في نيويورك في
وسط مانهاتن في شارع 57 ،
الفندق مغلق بالطبع
لعامة الناس
بدلاً من استخدام نصفه
لإيواء الخدمات الطبية  الموظفون تفاصيل آرت ديكو
هنا هو الشيء الوحيد
الذي لم يغير
الأقنعة لأنني الآن أقابل أشخاصًا آخرين ،
هناك مدخل بديل حيث
لا يتم الترحيب بي من قبل بواب أو حمال
بدلاً من ممرضة في معدات الوقاية الشخصية صعبة بالنسبة لي
نحن الآن
خدماتنا في DNA Rudy Tao ، متأكد من
أن المدير العام للفندق يدرك أن هذا
هو الضيافة في عصر Kovat 19
سوف تحتاج الفنادق إلى العمل بشكل مختلف ،
نحن محظوظون جدًا هنا لدينا
تخطيط مكاني ضخم لديك مدخلين
يمكننا تصميم الفندق  ولكن إذا لم تكن
لديك هذه الفرصة ولديك
ردهة صغيرة ولديك مطاعم مزدحمة ،
فعليك أن تنظر إليها بشكل
مختلف.
لذا فإن
احتياطاتهم متطرفة الآن حيث يتم
تعديل الخطة للغرف العامة
سيتم تطهيرها يوميًا
وسيتم تنظيف الأماكن العامة لفحص الإضاءة الخلفية
كل ساعة وسيتم توفير أطقم
بأقنعة ومعقم لليدين
للضيوف رئيس فورسيزونز العالمي
كريستيان  يقول كاتب إنهم
يعملون مع خبراء الصحة من جونز
هوبكنز ، فكلما تعلموا أكثر كلما
تطورت سياساتهم ، نريد أن
يكون لدينا نهج قائم على
العلم ، كما تعلم ريتشارد ، هناك الكثير من
الضوضاء الخلفية هنا في Saline مع
الحرص على التأسيس في
الحقائق والعلم ، وهل نضع في اعتبارنا
أن هناك الكثير مما لا نعرفه عن
هذا القدر الذي بدأ العالم يتحرك
فيه ، وهناك بصيص من زيادة الطلب
على حجوزات الفنادق
وفقًا لتحليل الضيافة من
Str
okay ونرى الأسبوع الماضي الرقم 32  في المائة في
الولايات المتحدة ، هذا أعلى من الشهر الماضي ،
لكن لنكن صريحين ، فهو أقل من
نصف ما كان عليه هذه المرة في الماضي
لن تكون هذه رحلة سلسة ،
أشعر أن كل أجزاء
العالم ستتحرك كل منطقة
بوتيرة مختلفة كما تراها بالفعل في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، وأجزاء مختلفة من
العالم ، وتطبق
مناهج مختلفة على جميع الفنادق
تعمل الآن على إعداد الخدمات اللوجستية لكيفية
إعادة فتحك في عالم كوفات في حالة
السماح بخدمة الغرف في عدد المرات التي تقوم فيها
بتنظيف الضيوف الذين لا يريدون تنظيف غرفهم ،
وتعقيم جميع هذه الغرف بشكل
يومي في حالة السماح للصالات الرياضية
بتناثر القائمة  تطول وتطول ولكنك
لم تعتقد أبدًا أنه سيتعين عليك التعامل مع
هذه الأشياء في حياتك الحالية مثل هذا النوع من الأشياء
في حياتك المهنية ، لم يكن هذا شيئًا
جديدًا لقد مررت
بأزمة مالية و 11 سبتمبر هنا في نيويورك و  الآن
مغطى 19 ، سيعيد تشكيلنا ، سيعيد
تشكيل هذه الصناعة ،
الميزة العظيمة للفندق هو أنه ملجأ
من الحياة المنزلية ، لذلك قال جورج برنارد
شو الآن أن الفنادق الكبرى مثل
فورسيزونز يجب أن تعيد تعريف ما يعنيه
أن تكون ملكي
إنها اللحظة التي انتظرت فيها المطاعم الواقعة على طول
شارع 23 جنوبًا لأننا
كنا نؤذي اليوم الأول من المرحلة الأولى
لإعادة الفتح بعد أن فرضت قيود فيروس كورونا
عليها قيودًا على طلبات تناول الطعام
خلال الشهرين الماضيين ، فقد رأينا الكثير في ذلك
العام 26 هذا هو  شيء لم
نشهده من قبل من قبل تحدٍ غير مسبوق
يتطلب إبداعًا غير مسبوق لحانة Crystal City Sports
حيث
يتخذ المالك John Finley وطاقمه
هذه الخطوة الأولى نحو التعافي ، نحن
متحمسون لأنها على الأقل
البداية التي تعلم أنه يمكنك البدء في
رؤية بصيصها  من الضوء قليلاً منذ
المرحلة الأولى من خطة فرجينيا المتقدمة للحاكم
يسمح للمطاعم بفتح
أماكن للجلوس في الهواء الطلق فقط ، أوه جي مثل
هذا المكان واختار العديد من الآخرين
تحويل مواقف السيارات الخاصة بهم إلى ساحات خارجية في
حوالي الساعة التاسعة صباحًا ، وكان لدينا شخص ما هنا
لتناول الإفطار  بحلول وقت الغداء ، التقينا
بعملاء مثل تيري كامبو يستمتع
ببيرة باردة يا إلهي ، هذا جيد لأنه يجلس
على أحد الطاولات العديدة التي تم
إعدادها  على بعد ستة أقدام نظرًا لأن التباعد الاجتماعي
يتطلب من العملاء سعداء
بالتواجد هنا ، وكذلك
سيساعد الخادم بالتأكيد في الحصول على هذا
المال الجيد على الرغم من أن Simone Bassett
وزملائها في العمل يجب أن يعملوا معها بشكل
أكثر صعوبة نظرًا لأن إعدادهم الخارجي الجديد
موجود بالفعل.  الشارع
من المطعم مهما كان المطلوب
للعودة إلى العمل ، فنحن جميعًا في هذا
معًا ، إنه ليس فردًا واحدًا ، إنه
ليس شارعًا كما هو معروف للجميع على
الأرجح حتى لو
لم تذهب أبدًا ولكن الآن في كوباكابانا
لا يفعل رجال الإنقاذ
إنهم يصطادونك من الماء ويطلبون منك الخروج من الرمال
تمامًا ، هذا
ما فعله أشهر فيروس في
العالم على شاطئه الأكثر شهرة أفرغه بمرسوم
من الحاكم ، لكن البداية عندما
لم يصدق الناس كورونا ، كما يقول  كان لدينا
تجمعات في حفلات الأكشاك في
الليل ، وكانت المدارس مغلقة ، لذا كان الناس
يأتون إلى الرمال مع أطفالهم ،
وكان يُسمح لك بالتجول في المنتزه حتى لو
كان من الصعب ارتداء قناع
الحاكم المحلي وتشغيله.  فرض هذه القيود
التي أغضبت الرئيس البرازيلي
جايا بورسين رو الذي قلل من أهمية
المرض ولكن يمكنني أن أفعل ذلك ، وبينما كنت
مغطاة 19 يعني المزيد من الشرطي في كوباكابانا ،
لا يزال هناك مساحة
لكشك كاتارينا الانفرادي تقريبًا لم يره ميغيل
أبدًا بهذا السوء إنه  أسوأ ما
قاله نحن منفتحون لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا بيع
شيء ما يتم إغلاقه هو الأسوأ ، نشك في
أنه سيكون مشغولًا في أي وقت قريبًا في الظهيرة
وأول شركة في كوكتيل
جعل
الأجانب ممنوعًا من الدخول إلى البرازيل ،
هذا العالم الأيقوني  مزيج من الأشخاص
الذين يعرفون أنهم ربما لا يجب أن يكونوا هنا
والمشردين الذين لا يزال لديهم مكان
آخر تذهبون إليه ، هذا مكان يضم
أسعد الذكريات بالنسبة للكثيرين في
قلب حلم ريو الأولمبي حتى
كتبوا أغانٍ عنه ولكن مثل
بقية  العالم يمر بتوقف مظلم
ويضطر إلى التساؤل عما
إذا كان طبيعيًا أم لا إذا عاد هو
نفسه تمامًا مثل الماضي
إذا كنت تخطط للطيران في وقت ما
قريبًا ، فهناك خطوات يمكنك اتخاذها من أجل
حافظ على صحتك وفقًا
لمراكز السيطرة على الأمراض
والوقاية منها ، فإن أول شيء تحتاج إلى
تقييمه قبل القيام بأي سفر هو
هل أنت مريض إذا كان لديك أي أعراض ،
ابق في المنزل أثناء تواجدك في المطار ،
تأكد من الحفاظ على إرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي.
على بعد ستة أقدام من
الآخرين كلما أمكن ذلك ، ارتدِ قناعًا في
جميع الأوقات وانتبه إلى كل سطح
تلمسه ولديك الكثير من
معقمات اليدين المتاحة وجاهزة للاستخدام بشكل
متكرر طوال رحلتك ،
كبير المراسلين الطبيين لـ CNN د.
يقترح سانجاي غوبتا الوصول إلى المطار
مبكرًا بما يكفي للسير إلى مبنى الركاب الخاص بك
بدلاً من ركوب مطار ترامب المغلق ،
حاول ألا تلمس الأسطح عند
البوابة ، وعلى الرغم من أن شركات الطيران تتخذ
خطوات إضافية لتنظيف وتعقيم
الطائرات بين الرحلات الجوية ، إلا أنه لا يؤذي ذلك.  للقيام
بمسح بسيط للأشياء الموجودة في
مقعدك عند صعودك على متن د.  يقول غوبتا
إنك سترغب في تشغيل مقبض الدوران
فوقك على ارتفاع للمساعدة في تحريك الهواء
أمامك ، ومن المحتمل أن تكسر
جزيئات الفيروس أخيرًا إذا كنت لا
تشعر بالراحة أثناء السفر ،
تواصل مع شركة الطيران الخاصة بك وحاول تحريك
رحلتك لهذا اليوم.  دقيقة الصحة أنا
ماندي جيثر